it's a journey fraught with danger but
one that thousands of refugees are
willing to make crossing the
Mediterranean from North Africa
illegally heading for an uncertain
future in the European Union
now most refugees are migrants and
migrants end up in Spain or Greece now
these numbers from the UN show arrivals
so far this year but Italy hits the
headlines most often because of its
hardline approach to unofficial rescue
missions Rome claims these are colluding
with people traffickers now Italy's
migrant backlash grew last year with the
election of the populist government and
its far-right interior minister Matteo
salvini new legislation passed this week
threatens captains of rescue vessels
with fines of up to 1 million euros if
they enter Italian ports without
permission the government also wants
other EU countries to take in most of
the refugees and migrants landing in
Italy d-damn news Mack Xander joined a
Seawatch rescue mission of the Libyan
coast and sent us this report takeoff
from an undisclosed location
the German NGO Seawatch is taking us on
a reconnaissance flight over the
Mediterranean chi mafia and pilot yun
have one main objective saving lives
this is the central Mediterranean route
northern Africa and Europe the crew of
this search plane is looking for
migrants who attempted the dangerous
crossing often all rubber boats and
putting their lives at great risk
finding them is like looking for a
needle in a haystack and conditions are
anything but ideal the Seawatch aircraft
moon bird mainly operates in the search
and rescue zone off the coast of western
libya an area that spans more than 350
kilometers of coastline this is where
migrant boats set off on their perilous
journey to Italy and Malta footage from
an earlier mission shows how that looks
dozens of people on an overcrowded
rubber dinghy passengers often spend
days out at sea exposed to the Sun and
with limited supplies people have been
on the water for days are usually
dehydrated desperate and in a serious
medical condition those really are
emergencies that have to be evacuated as
soon as possible after hours up in the
air we spot a suspicious object of the
water that's the sunken rubber dinghy
for now we don't know what happened to
the people on board these cheap
inflatable boats are not made to last
and sometimes sink after days out at sea
even if kai and his crew managed to spot
a boats in distress it doesn't mean the
passengers will be brought to safety due
to a crackdown on NGOs there are very
few rescue boats left on the water and
merchant vessels tried to avoid the
affected area altogether often the
Libyan Coast Guard is the last resort
for kai and his colleagues this is a
frustrating experience
I want the people to reach a safe haven
I want these people to get to Europe and
I want them to cross the ocean safely
and not be brought back illegally but as
long as ships are being seized rescue
capacities are being cut and we're the
only ones keeping an eye on the water we
have to deal with situations like this
we are back on the ground where exactly
we cannot save kai and Mejia are aware
that their organization's activities are
being closely monitored since EU
governments such as Italy have started
to crack down on rescue NGOs see watch
faces public criticism and accusations
that they are aiding people smugglers a
claim that Maria vigorously rejects we
would never communicate with people
smugglers in no capacity they're simply
criminals who've made a business with
people who suffer and make money out of
the circumstance that they're so
desperate and see no other way than
reaching out to them listen I've
sensitive in here kai says these claims
are used to paint them as criminals and
distract from the real issue
you mean lives have to be saved for me
that's not up for debate
and there's too much discussion going on
about it about who should be saved and
thus marcado's fu despite the mounting
pressure kai and Maria say they will
continue to go on missions for as long
as they are allowed to or until their
work becomes no longer necessary I'm now
joined by Charlie Axley from the UN
refugee agency the UNHCR a welcome mr.
Yaxley now why is it that NGOs are
having to rescue refugees and migrants
at sea and not the Coast Guard well what
we're seeing right now is a real lack of
search-and-rescue capacity on the
Mediterranean there needs to be a
significant increase of that one of the
major players
doing this at the moment off the Libyan
coast is the Libyan Coast Guard but
there's a huge issue there where that
they are then returns to Libya and taken
to detention centers such as to Jorah
where last month 50 people were killed
after an airstrike hit them while they
were trapped inside so what can be done
instead well we need to see States lift
the current legal and logistical
restrictions on NGO boats NGOs have
played a crucial role on the
Mediterranean saving lives and they
should be allowed to carry out their
operations but we also need to see EU
state vessels like we saw in previous
years return to the Mediterranean we
need their European States to bring back
a program like that to prevent the the
the crisis of deaths that we currently
see on the Mediterranean but is there
any sign that this is happening because
your organization has warned that
punishing private rescue ships could
prevent lives from being saved in the
Mediterranean what will happen if these
NGOs stop operating where as a real
concern here that you know the NGOs will
be increasingly deterred we may end up
in a situation where there are no NGO of
boats operating and then that will place
a greater burden on on commercial ships
and with this new law that has passed we
fear that ship masters of commercial
ships may hesitate or even ignore
distress calls how a fear of being stuck
for sea with those rescued passengers
for days on end I mean since April the
situation in Libya has deteriorated
substantially and we cannot turn a blind
eye to the suffering that's taking place
there the number of arrivals attempting
to reach Europe is down significantly
compared to previous years back to
pre-crisis levels so it's a question of
developing a solution where there's
cooperation among States
search-and-rescue capacity is
substantially increased and states agree
a mechanism on how to share
responsibility for hosting them
afterwards then what does the UNHCR
think needs to be the top priority in
dealing with this migration across the
Mediterranean
well the the sea journeys themselves are
really only one aspect and really the
final aspect of this route err any any
attempts to address this situation has
to have a holistic and comprehensive
outlook we need to look first of all at
why people are fleeing in the first
place from their home countries there
are currently more than 15 unresolved
conflicts in eastern West Africa that
are prompting people to flee their homes
at the same time in other countries but
also countries of asylum they need
support with strengthening their Asylum
systems and with strategic development
assistance so that people feel they are
able to live their lives or rebuild
their lives in the case of refugees only
then will we see a change where people
no longer feel the desperation that they
put their hands in the lives of these
unscrupulous smugglers and traffickers
who organized these routes charlie
actually from the UNHCR thank you very
much for talking to DW thank you